aquí tenemos un trapezoide en el plano
coordenada y lo que queremos hacer es
encontrar el área de este trapezoide con
lo que nos dan en este diagrama los
invito a que pausa en el vídeo para que
traten de hacerlo por su cuenta
sabemos cómo encontrar el área de un
trapezoide y tenemos videos en donde
derivamos esta fórmula para ponerlo de
manera sencilla el área de un trapezoide
es igual al promedio de las longitudes
de la base digamos base 1 + base 2
multiplicado por la altura y aquí cuáles
serán nuestras bases y cuál será la
altura bueno nuestra base 1 puede ser el
segmento cl la longitud de este segmento
cl base 2 tendrá otro color y será el
segmento que va de un wv la longitud del
segmento o w y nuestra altura h será
esta distancia el segmento wv n la
longitud del segmento w m esta línea que
intersecta al segmento cl con un ángulo
recto
así que si conocemos la longitud de cada
uno de estos elementos podremos
encontrar
el área de nuestro tape soy de si esto
no les parece familiar los invito a que
vean los diferentes vídeos que tenemos
al respecto en donde mostramos cómo
encontramos esta fórmula por ejemplo al
descomponer esta figura en dos
triángulos y un rectángulo pero bueno
veamos si podemos encontrar esta área
bueno primero vamos a encontrar a b1 b1
es la longitud del segmento cl y bueno
nosotros conocemos cuáles son las
coordenadas de cada uno de estos puntos
y podríamos aplicar la fórmula de la
distancia y recordemos que la fórmula de
la distancia es una aplicación del
teorema de pitágoras así que esto va a
ser la raíz cuadrada del cuadrado de
esta distancia nuestro cambio en x al
cuadrado que va desde x igual a menos
cuatro hasta x igual a 8 así que nuestro
cambio en x es igual a 8 menos menos 4
que es igual a 12 y nuestro cambio en
que va desde nuestra y igual a menos 1
hasta allí igual a 5 nuestro cambio en g
es igual a 5 menos menos 1
es igual a 6 y lo podemos ver aquí 1 2 3
4 5 6 y la longitud del segmento que nos
interesa es este de aquí la hipotenusa
de este triángulo rectángulo que tiene
un lado igual a 12 y otro lado igual a 6
así que la longitud de este segmento
usando el teorema de pitágoras ya que
recordamos que la fórmula de la
distancia es una aplicación de este
teorema va a ser igual a nuestro cambio
en x al cuadrado 12 al cuadrado más
nuestro cambio en al cuadrado 6 al
cuadrado la raíz cuadrada de 144 36 es
igual a ciento ochenta 180 es igual a 36
por 5 que es igual la raíz cuadrada de
36 6 por la raíz cuadrada de 5 ahora
encontremos a b2 nuevamente esto es
igual a la raíz cuadrada del cambio de x
al cuadrado más el cambio de g al
cuadrado aquí podemos tener nuestro
triángulo rectángulo más o menos así
nuestro cambio en x es igual bueno aquí
vamos desde x igual a menos 2 y llega
hasta 4 positivo así que el cambio en x
es igual a 4 - menos 2 nuestro cambio en
x es 6 y ahora nuestro cambio en va a
ser vamos desde igual a 5 hasta allí
igual a 8 así que nuestro cambio en g es
igual a 8 menos 5 que es igual a 3
aplicamos el teorema de pitágoras para
encontrar esta longitud de aquí la raíz
cuadrada de nuestro cambio en x al
cuadrado 6 al cuadrado más nuestro
cambio en al cuadrado que es 3 al
cuadrado esto es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 36 más 9 que es igual a 45
la raíz cuadrada de 45 y esto es igual a
la raíz cuadrada de 9 por 5 lo que nos
da que esto es igual a 3 por la raíz
cuadrada de 5 y ahora sólo nos queda una
distancia más que encontrar tenemos que
encontrar nuestra h&h va a ser igual si
vamos desde w hasta él
nuestro cambio en x es 2 ya que vamos
desde x 4 hasta x 6 si lo quieren hacer
numéricamente decimos que nuestro valor
final es 6 nuestro valor inicial es 4
por lo que tendremos 6 menos cuatro
igualados así que esto es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de 2 al cuadrado más el
cuadrado de nuestro cambio en g
y nuestro cambio en -4 pero como lo
vamos a elevar al cuadrado pues el signo
no va a importar esto va a ser igual a
la raíz cuadrada de 2 al cuadrado más
menos 4 al cuadrado que es 4 16 igual a
20 y la raíz cuadrada de 20 es igual a
la raíz cuadrada de 4 por 5 que es igual
a 2 por la raíz cuadrada de 5 y está
bien que aquí sigamos teniendo una raíz
cuadrada de 5 ahora vamos a sustituir
todo esto en nuestra expresión original
por lo que el área de nuestro trapezoide
va a ser igual a un medio que multiplica
a b1 b1 es 6 por raíz cuadrada de 5 más
de 2 que es 3 por raíz cuadrada de 5
cerramos el paréntesis y lo
multiplicamos por 2 o raíz cuadrada de 5
veamos cómo podemos simplificar esto 6 x
raíz cuadrada de 53 por raíz cuadrada de
5 es igual a 9 por raíz cuadrada de 5 y
este un medio por este 2 se van a
cancelar
y nos quedan nueve por raíz cuadrada de
cinco por raíz cuadrada de cinco y raíz
cuadrada de cinco por raíz cuadrada de
cinco nos va a dar cinco así que esto es
nueve por cinco igual a 45 lo que nos da
45 unidades cuadradas como área de este
trapezoide